There is one extremely common mistake
that absolutely destroys your
confidence. It makes you look less
confident. It makes you feel less
confident. It makes people move away
from you. And it looks and sounds like
this.
>> I wanted to say that I'm sorry I hurt
you. I hope to make amends.
>> So before I share exactly what's going
on from a charisma perspective, a little
context. This is Ned Fulmer. He's one of
the former Try Guys. And in this video,
he is apologizing for an affair that he
had several years ago that resulted in
his cancellation.
>> 3 years ago, I cheated on my wife with
my producer.
>> Now, what is happening here? What is
destroying his confidence? What is the
thing that people in the comments are
sort of hooking into and noticing and
that is probably happening in your life
in high stress situations? What is
happening is that his voice is
unsupported by his diaphragm, which is
to say essentially he is not speaking
from his belly. I betrayed my spouse,
uh, co-workers, friends, family.
>> Now, what happens when we are nervous or
we're not fully on board what's
happening in our lives? Say we're in an
interview and we have imposter syndrome.
We're afraid. We're talking to someone
that we're really attracted to and we're
not sure that they'd like us. We
constrict in order to control what's
going on, or so we think. What is
actually happening here is that the
fight orflight mechanism is basically
lifting us up out of our grounded sense
of who we are. We start to elevate
physically and also psychologically out
of a rested position in our belly, in
our gut, in our butt touching the
ground, in our feet on the ground. Up,
up, up, up, up until we get really
tight. And then we talk like this and
then the words just tumble out of our
mouth and we have this pinched vocaf fry
sort of thing going on that destroys
your confidence.
>> I guess I was too afraid to say how I
was actually feeling. And
>> this is not to judge yourself or Ned or
anyone else. The thing that feels
confident when people speak is when the
voice is supported. And essentially
internally what it feels like is you're
communicating in a straight line through
your belly, your chest, your throat,
your eyes, they're all headed the same
way. When you feel some part of
somebody's trying to get out of the
situation and they're kind of like this,
that feels like they lack confidence.
And it sort of is. Their psyche is
fragmented. One part of them wants to
run away and the other part of them is
trying to stay here. and you get this
really tense, uncomfortable thing that
just feels like I don't trust that
person. Whether or not they're
trustworthy doesn't matter. They're not
aligned.
>> I don't think it's fair that as a
society you're put in that position.
It's certainly not true.
>> If you start to feel this, you know the
feeling. You don't know what to do with
your hands. Words are going to tumble
out of your mouth. You lose your sense
of sitting or standing exactly where you
are, and you're not sure what to say.
Pause. If you need to step out, go to
the bathroom. But if you can't do that,
even in the moment, take one deep
breath. Feel where you are seated or
standing. Right now, I'm seated. And try
to make the next thing that you say
connect your belly to your vocal cords.
Your belly, your heart, your vocal
cords. And speak in that straight line.
And I do want to take a moment to say
that this is what you see when you see
someone like Martin Luther King Jr.
giving a speech. It is full alignment.
That resonant voice is not simply that
he was biologically made different,
which he, you know, he has a a bassy
deep voice. It's that full alignment.
>> I have a dream. My poor little children
will one day live in a nation where they
will not be judged by the color of their
skin, but by the content of their
character. I have a dream.
>> You can also see this in someone like a
Craig Ferguson, who can hit a very high
register when he's excited to see
someone.
>> You look sensational. I mean,
sensational. Oh, thank you.
>> Look at you. Look at you, woman. You
look sensational.
>> But it still has this sense of fullness
to it.
>> Take your time. Take your time.
>> Don't just rush in there, blow it, and
suck it and chew it.
So when you do that, you're going to
come across as more confident, but also
the literal words that you say will be
different because when you are aligned
and when you can drop out of that fight
orflight freakout response that can make
you sort of just blurt things out that
you don't really mean or apologize when
you're not totally on board or
communicate that you don't believe that
you deserve this job or this person or
whatever. When you can drop out of that
and speak from alignment, the words that
you choose will be true for you. And
they might start with, "Wow, I just
realized I was really nervous in this
interview. I need a second. Okay, I'm
good." And then you're back. You're in
full alignment. You're able to
communicate clearly and confidently. So,
I hope that that helps. One small thing,
but it makes a huge difference if you
get it right. If you're interested in
more tips like this, you might be
interested in Charisma University. It
has a lot of confidence and presentation
tips that are just like this. very
superficial surface level stuff that you
can grab immediately with deep deep
roots in terms of what connects with
other people, what's going to make you
feel more confident in yourself. So,
it's not just showy presentation parlor
tricks. It's actually a deeprooted sense
of confidence that is changing over the
30 days. If you want to check that
course out and join, you can click here
or in the description below. Either way,
I hope that you have enjoyed this video
and I look forward to seeing you in the
next